[Music]
hey guys now I got a lot of questions on
skincare on my channel and I thought all
right look I need to make more videos
about this and give you guys more tips
and so I thought I need to start right
at the beginning and so in this video
I'm gonna give you guys a basic skincare
routine tutorial that's gonna help you
now the most important thing that you
need to understand when it comes to
skincare is that you need products that
are made for your skin for example do
you have dry skin or oily skin or a
combination and then do you have pimples
an is your skin very sensitive and what
about acne scars and blackheads and
whiteheads and wrinkles even and then
what about dark circles under your eyes
you see most products are not equipped
to handle all the needs of your skin and
so that's why great products like
geology is awesome for this you know I
saw how famous they got over this last
few years they were even mentioned a
places like Men's Health Men's Journal
and Esquire and I also won a lot of
awards because their products actually
work why does it work because they give
you the opportunity to customize your
own skin care products with their help
of course and so it addresses those
unique needs of your skin now how do I
know it works well I've been trying it
out for the last almost two months I
tried it out right after I did my
research on them and so in this video I
asked them to sponsor this video where I
can give you guys a basic skincare
routine tutorial and they said yes so
thank you guys so how do you get the
right skin care products for your skin
well all you got to do is head over to
their website and click here on get
started then you just answer that quick
questions so that they can personalize a
set of products for your unique skin
now these questions are very important
because this is how they determine the
needs of your skin this ensures that
they add the right ingredients into your
skin care products they also ask you to
upload a clear picture of yourself just
to make sure and then voila
look how cool this is and then once
you're done they create it and send it
to you for a 30 day trial so you get
your complete set of four different
products the everyday face wash the
vital morning face cream the repairing
night cream and the nourishing eye cream
now let me show you how the skincare
routine works the first step is to wash
your face with the everyday face wash
Geology sends you two of them with your
subscription I got two one for the
shower and one for the zinc I think
that's awesome because I always forget
my face was on the zinc when I'm in the
shower
so just wash your face with lukewarm
water the container says warm water but
lukewarm water is better for your skin
than warm water you got to wash your
face in the morning and also at night
and then the second step is to put on
the face cream in the morning you use
the vital morning face cream and then at
night you use the repairing light cream
and then the last step is to put on the
eye cream but only do it at night now
I've been using it for about two months
now and as you can see my skin is great
I got no pimples my face is clear and
clean and then another thing I like
about geology and you would like too is
that your subscription comes with a free
consultation now this is just to make
sure that you get the right skincare
products for your skin if you want to
try them out I got you a 30% discount
for your first trial and if you think
about it is like one US dollar per day
which is pretty cheap for the quality
that you get I added a discount code and
a link for you in the video description
if you want to try it out
now remember great skin comes with care
and time it's not just about the
products but how you take care of your
skin and so if you want more tips on how
to take care of your skin check out one
of these videos and we'll help y'all
I'll see you there cheers guys